whatever whoever was responsible for
what happened in beirut
has managed to push a country already on
the edge
over the cliff into the pit of
catastrophe
beirut was the portal through which i
myself
entered the arab world more than 40
years
ago i fell in love with it at first
sight
as anyone who's ever been there will
tell you
the same lebanon is a simply magical
place
whereas the brochures used to say you
could ski in the mountains in the
morning and water ski
in the mediterranean in the afternoon
that was how
it was packaged of course the reality of
many hundreds of thousands of people
living in palestinian refugee camps
or living in poverty as an oppressed
sect in lebanon unseen
unnoticed and certainly not acknowledged
for decades has all changed
lebanon by virtue of its very creation
by the sykes pico agreement its division
from its motherland in syria has
always been a place of multiple crises
crisscrossing the confessional and
sectarian nature
of the country and yet despite the civil
war
despite the crises at the legendary
fortitude and ingenuity of the lebanese
people
allowed them to drag themselves out of
the pit of 1970s civil war
and rebuild that magical place a magnet
for travelers from all over the world
not least
travelers from the arabian gulf and from
other
arab countries three billion dollars
worth of devastation
in an instant when the port the harbor
of beirut blew up as far as we know
by accident though who can tell in that
part of the world
three billion dollars a hundred dead and
thousands injured already collapsing
hospitals
due to economic crises have now been
overwhelmed by the sheer scale of the
casualty list but the explosion in
beirut is merely the proximate cause
of this catastrophic crisis
lebanon was already in severe trouble
as a result of sanctions our old friend
sanctions again the sanctions against
syria have been
extended into lebanon as the united
states
empire tries to reconfigure
political power in lebanon but there are
some facts
that simply will not shift hezbollah
the majority shiite political party
has overwhelming support from the
overwhelmingly most numerous
section of the lebanese population their
alliance with the legendary
christian military officer now president
general
aaron makes them a powerful coalition
that simply cannot be wished away
those who want to wish them away have
persuaded the united states
administration
that lebanon is an enemy the price
and even availability of staples will
now be
threatened in a potentially deadly way
by the utter devastation of the port
through which almost everything that
lebanon eats
comes in if the united states had
any sense it would now call off the war
against lebanon it would flood lebanon
with humanitarian aid and financial
credits
it would bail out lebanon and gain
the honor that they long ago
lost gain to the hearts and minds of the
people
not just in lebanon but throughout the
arab world where lebanon
is a national treasure but i'm not sure
that the united states
has a heart or even a head
certainly a head with a brain in it it's
likely that attempts will be made
to try and blame others for the
catastrophe which has occurred
donald trump said from the podium that
his great generals had told them
that the catastrophe was caused by an
attack
by a bomb that's not what the lebanese
government say but
inquiries are at an early stage
it would be hardly any surprise
if bomb and attack it was after all
israel has been attacking lebanon almost
every day certainly
every week for as long as i've been
going there that's
more than 40 years it might not be
any of the parties involved in the
complicated political situation
in lebanon it could be someone else
entirely we'll have to wait and see what
is harvested by the
inquiry now underway but if history is
anything to go by
the rumor mill will make the judgment
long before the inquiry report
is published lebanon's economic
catastrophe and its political crises
are about to get much worse
as for the people of the world i think
our responsibility
is clear the whole world has to rise up
now
and demand that we save lebanon
a precious jewel of the orient